I've done a bunch of videos
already on respiration.
I think even before those
videos, you had a sense that
we need oxygen and that
we release CO2.
And if you watched the videos on
respiration, you know that
we need the oxygen in order to
metabolize our food, in order
to turn our food into ATPs
that can then drive other
types of cellular functions--
or anything that we have to
do; move, or breathe, or think,
or everything that we
have to do.
And that through the process of
respiration, we break down
those sugars and we release
carbon dioxide.
So in this video, what I want to
do is take a big step back
and think about how we actually
get our oxygen into
our body and how we release it
back out into the atmosphere.
Another way to think about it is
how we ventilate ourselves.
How do we get the oxygen in, and
how do we get the carbon
dioxide out?
And I think any of us could at
least start off this video.
It starts off in either
our nose or our mouth.
I always have a clogged sinus
so I often have to
deal with my mouth.
I sleep with my mouth often.
But it always starts in our
nose or our mouths.
Let me draw someone with
a nose and a mouth.
So let's say that this
is my person.
Maybe his mouth will be open
so that he can breathe.
His eyes aren't important,
but just so
you know it's a person.
So this is my test subject
or the person I'm
going to use to diagram.
That's his ear.
Maybe he has a bit of a-- let's
give him some hair.
All of that is irrelevant,
but this is our guy.
This is the guy that's going to
show us how we take air in
and how we take air
out of the body.
So let's go inside
of this guy.
I can draw his outside
first. Let me see how
well I can do this.
So this is outside the guy.
That doesn't look right.
Let's say the guy looks
something like this and he's
got-- this is his shoulders.
That's our guy.
All right.
So in our mouth, we have our
oral cavity right there, which
is just the space that
our mouth creates.
We have our oral cavity.
I could draw our tongue and all
of that and maybe I will.
Maybe I'll draw the tongue.
But you have this space inside
of the mouth-- call that the
oral cavity.
Oral for mouth, cavity for
space, or hole, or opening.
And then also you have your
nostrils and they open up into
a nasal cavity.
So that's another big space
just like this.
And we know that they connect at
the back of our nose or the
back of our mouth.
And this passage right here
where they connect is called
the pharynx.
When your air goes through your
nose-- they say breathing
through your nose is better,
probably because it gets
filtered by your nose hairs and
it gets warmed up and and
what not, but you can breathe
through either side.
The air goes in through either
your nasal cavity or your oral
cavity and then comes back
through your pharynx and then
the pharynx splits
into two pipes.
One for-- well, one, air can
go down either one, but the
other one is for food.
So your pharynx gets split.
In the back you have your
esophagus-- and we'll talk
more about the esophagus
in a future video.
In the back you have your
esophagus and in the front--
let me draw a little dividing
line there.
In the front, maybe this-- let
me make it connect like that.
I was using yellow.
I'm going to use yellow to
continue and I'm going to use
green for the air.
So it divides just like that.
So behind your air pipe, you
have your esophagus.
Let me make that
another color.
And then right here
is your larynx.
And I'm going to concern
ourselves with the larynx.
Esophagus is where your
food goes down.
We know that we eat food
with our mouth as well.
So this is where we
want our food to
go-- down the esophagus.
But the focus of this video
is our ventilation.
What do we do with our air?
So I'm going to focus as the air
goes through our larynx.
And the larynx is also
our voicebox.
So as you hear me talking right
now, there are these
little things right about here
that are vibrating at just the
right frequencies and I'm able
to shape the sound with my
mouth to make this video.
So that's also your voicebox,
but I won't focus
on that right now.
It's called a voicebox because
of this whole anatomical
structure that looks something
like that.
But then after the air passes
through the larynx-- this is
on the way in-- it goes to the
trachea, which is essentially
just the pipe for air.
The esophagus is the
pipe for food.
Let me write this down.
And then from the trachea-- and
the trachea is actually a
reasonably rigid structure.
It has cartilage around
it and it makes
sense that it has cartilage.
You don't want-- you can imagine
a hose-- if it bent a
lot, you wouldn't be able to get
a lot of water through it,
or a lot of air through it.
So you don't want this
thing to bend a lot.
So that's why it needs to have
some rigidity-- so that's why
it has cartilage around it.
And then it splits into two
tubes-- and I think you know
where these two tubes
are going to.
And I'm not drawing this
in super detail.
I just want you to get the idea
of them, but these two
tubes are the bronchi-- or
each one is a bronchus.
And they also have cartilage,
so they're fairly rigid, but
the bronchi keep splitting.
They keep splitting into smaller
and smaller tubes just
like that and at some point,
they stop having cartilage.
They stop being reasonably
rigid, but they
keep splitting off.
So I'll just draw them as
these little lines.
At some point they become
such thin things.
They just keep splitting off.
So the air just keeps splitting
off and spread and
goes down the different paths.
And when the bronchi no longer
have cartilage around them,
they're no longer rigid.
The first of those are called--
or actually all the
tubes after that point are
called bronchioles.
These are bronchioles.
So for example, that we could
call a bronchiole.
And there's nothing
fancy here.
It's just a pipe that
just gets thinner
and thinner and thinner.
We've labeled the different
parts of the pipes different
things, but the idea is, let's
take it through our mouth or
our nose and we just keep
dividing and keep dividing
this main division into two
different paths that takes us
into each of our lungs.
Let me draw this guy's
lungs here.
And these bronchi-- or the
bronchi split into the lungs--
the bronchioles are in the
lungs and eventually the
bronchioles terminate.
And this is where it
gets interesting.
They keep dividing smaller and
smaller, thinner and thinner
and thinner, into these little
air sacs, just like that.
At the end of every super small
bronchiole are these
little air sacs-- super small
air sacs-- and I'm going to
talk about these air
sacs in a second.
And these are called alveoli.
So I've used a lot of
fancy words, but the
general idea is simple.
Air comes in through a pipe.
The pipe gets thinner and
thinner and thinner and they
end up at these little
air sacs.
And you're saying, well,
how does that get the
oxygen into my system?
Well, the key here is that these
air sacs are super small
and have very, very, very
thin walls-- or
I guess thin membranes.
So let me zoom in.
So if I were to zoom in on one
of these alveoli-- and just to
give you an idea, these are
super duper duper small.
I've drawn them fairly large
here, but each alveoli-- let
me draw a little bit bigger.
Let me draw these air sacs.
So you have these air
sacs like this.
And then you have a
bronchiole that's
terminating in that air sac.
Maybe a bronchiole is
terminating in another air sac
just like that-- another set
of air sacs just like that.
Each of these are only 200 to
300 microns in diameter.
So that distance right there--
let me switch colors-- that
distance right there is
200 to 300 microns.
And in case you don't know what
a micron is, a micron is
a millionth of a meter--
or you can view it as a
thousandth of a millimeter.
So this is 200 thousandths
of a millimeter.
Or you can think of them as--
and this is actually a very
easy way to visualize it-- this
is about one fifth of a
millimeter.
So if I actually try to draw it
on the screen-- if you made
this full screen, a millimeter
is about that far.
Maybe a little farther
than that.
Maybe about that far.
So imagine a fifth of that and
that's what we're talking
about the diameter of
one of these things.
And just to put it in the
whole scheme relative to
cells, the average
cell in the human
body is about 10 microns.
So this is only about 20 or 30
cells in diameter or relative
to the average cell
in the human body.
So these have a super
thin membrane.
If you view them as balloons,
the balloon is very thin--
pretty much one cell thick and
they're connected to the
bloodflow-- or actually, a
better way to think about is
that our circulatory system
passes right next to each of
these things.
So you have blood vessels that
come from the heart and they
want to be oxygenated.
In general, the blood vessels
that don't have oxygen-- and
I'm going to do this in a lot
more detail when I make the
videos about the heart and our
circulation system-- the blood
vessels that don't have oxygen--
de-oxygenated blood
is a little bit darker.
It looks a little
bit purplish.
So I'll draw it as blue.
So these are vessels that are
coming from the heart.
So this blood right here has no
oxygen in it or it's been
de-oxygenated or it has very
little oxygen in it.
And the word for the blood
vessels that comes from the
heart are arteries.
Let me write that down.
I'll review that again when
we cover it in the heart.
So arteries are blood vessels
from the heart.
And you've probably
heard of arteries.
Vessels that go to the heart
are called veins.
This is really important to keep
in mind because later on,
you're going to see that
arteries don't always carry
oxygen or they're always not
de-oxygenated and veins always
aren't one way or the other.
We're going to go into a lot
more detail when we actually
cover the heart and the
circulatory system, but just
remember, arteries go away.
Veins go to the heart.
So here, these are arteries
going away from the heart to
the lungs, to the alveoli
because they want the blood
that's traveling in them
to get oxygen.
So what's going to happen is
that the air is flowing
through the bronchioles and
circulating around the
alveoli, filling the alveoli--
and as they fill the alveoli,
the little molecules of oxygen
are allowed to cross the
membrane of the alveoli
and essentially be
absorbed into the blood.
I'll do a lot more on that when
we talk about hemoglobin
and red blood cells, but you
just have to realize that
there's just a lot
of capillaries.
Capillaries are just super small
blood vessels that allow
air to pass-- essentially oxygen
and carbon dioxide
molecules to pass
between them.
These have a lot of capillaries
on them that allow
the exchange of gases.
So the oxygen can go into this
blood and so once the oxygen--
so this is the vessel that's
coming from the heart and then
it's just a tube.
So then once it gets the oxygen,
it's going to go back
to the heart.
And so essentially this is the
point where this vessel, this
pipe, part of our circulatory
system, goes from being an
artery-- because it's coming
from the heart-- to a vein
because it's going back
to the heart.
And there's a special word for
these arteries and veins.
They're called pulmonary
arteries and veins.
So going away from the heart to
the lungs, to the alveoli,
these are the pulmonary
arteries.
And going back to the heart
are the pulmonary veins.
Now you're saying, Sal, what
does pulmonary mean?
Well, pulmo comes from the
Latin for the lungs.
It literally means the arteries
that are of the lungs
or that go to the lungs
and the veins that
come from the lungs.
So anytime people talk about
pulmonary anything, they're
talking about our lungs-- or
maybe something related to how
we breathe.
So it's a good word to know.
So anyway, you have your oxygen
coming in through your
mouth or your nose, through the
pharynx-- it could fill
your stomach.
We can blow up our stomach
like a balloon, but that
doesn't help us actually get
oxygen to our blood stream.
But the oxygen will come through
our larynx, into our
trachea, through the bronchi,
eventually in bronchioles,
ending up in alveoli and being
able to be absorbed into what
where the arteries, but then
we're going to go back and
then essentially oxygenate
the blood.
The red blood cells become red
once the hemoglobin becomes
very red or scarlet once it
actually has the oxygen and
then we go back.
But at the same time, this
isn't just about getting
oxygen into our arteries
or onto the hemoglobin.
It's also about releasing
carbon dioxide.
So these blue arteries coming
from the lungs are also going
to release carbon dioxide
into the alveoli.
And these will be exhaled.
So we have oxygen coming in.
Other things will be coming in,
but the O2 is what gets
absorbed in the alveoli.
And then when we breathe out,
we're going to have carbon
dioxide that was in our blood,
but then it gets absorbed into
the alveoli and they
get squeezed out.
I'm going to tell you in a
second how it gets squeezed.
It's actually that squeezing out
that actually-- when the
air goes back out, it can
vibrate my vocal cords and
it'll allow me to talk, but I'm
not going to go into too
much detail about that.
So the last thing to consider
about this whole pulmonary
system or about our lungs is,
how does it force the air in
and how does it force
the air out?
And the way it's done is really
kind of like a-- you
could imagine it's kind of a
pump or a balloon-- is that we
have this huge layer
of flat muscles.
Let me pick a good color here.
Right below the lungs--
and this is
called a thoracic diaphragm.
And so when it's relaxed, it
kind of has this arch shape,
and so the lungs are kind
of squeezed in.
They don't have a
lot of volume.
But when I essentially breathe
in, what's happening is this
thoracic diaphragm is contracted
and when it's
contracted, it gets shorter, but
more importantly, it opens
up the space where
my lungs are.
So my lungs can fill
up that space.
So what it does is, it
essentially-- it's like
pulling a balloon larger,
making the
volume of my lungs larger.
And when you make the volume of
something larger-- so the
lungs will become larger as
my thoracic diaphragm is
contracted and it kind of arches
down, creates more
space-- and as the volume of
something becomes larger, the
pressure inside of
them goes down.
If you remember from physics,
the pressure
times volume is a constant.
So when we breathe in, our brain
is essentially telling
our diaphragm to contract.
We have more space
around our lungs.
Our lungs expand to
fill the space.
We have less pressure here than
we have outside-- or you
can view it as negative
pressure.
So air always wants to go from
high pressure to low pressure
and so air is going to
flow into our lungs.
And hopefully there'll be some
oxygen there that can then
essentially go into our alveoli
and end up in our
arteries and then go back in the
veins as oxygen attached
to hemoglobin.
I'll talk more about
that in detail.
And then when we stop
contracting the diaphragm, it
goes back to this
arched position.
It contracts.
It's kind of like
a rubber band.
It contracts back the lungs and
it essentially expels the
air back and now that air's
going to have a lot more
carbon dioxide.
And just to get a sense of-- I
can look at my lungs-- I can't
look at them, but they
don't seem too large.
How do I get enough oxygen in
them-- and the key is, is that
because of this branching
process and the alveoli, the
inside surface area of the lungs
are actually much larger
than you can imagine-- or
actually than I could have
imagined had someone
not told me.
So it actually turns out-- I
looked it up-- the internal
surface area of your alveoli--
so the total surface area
where the oxygen can be absorbed
in or the carbon
dioxide can be absorbed out from
the blood-- it's actually
75 square meters.
That's meters, not feet.
If you think about it, that's
like a-- imagine some type of
a tarp or a field.
That's almost nine
by nine meters.
That's almost 27 by
27 square feet.
That's the size of some
people's backyards.
That's how much surface air you
have inside of your lungs.
It's all folded up.
That's how it gets jammed into
what look like relatively
small lungs.
But that's what gives us enough
surface area for enough
of the air, enough of the
oxygen, to cross the alveoli
membrane into our blood system
and enough of the carbon
dioxide to go back in.
And just to have a sense of how
many alveoli we had-- I
told you that they're very
small-- we actually have 300
million in each lung.
In each lung, we have
300 million alveoli.
So anyway, hopefully that gives
you a decent sense of
how we at least get oxygen
into our blood system and
carbon dioxide out of it.
In the next video, I'll talk
more about our actual
circulatory system and how we
get the oxygen from the lungs
to the rest of the body and
how do we get the carbon
dioxide from the rest of the
body into the lungs?